time on escape pods and roller skates
are getting a motorized boost but our
electric wheels easier to ripen their
traditional counterparts or harder I
want to know how difficult it is to ride
with electronic power and I'm going to
test three gadgets and danilo too and we
want to find out what they really can do
I borrowed a crow together with my
electric vehicles danilo Baron has a
shop in Berlin called scooter heaven
with a good selection I chose the
airwheel the one wheel and a pair of
rocket skates I'm gavest are Cena you've
got 10 to 11 kilos here in is kilo may I
go ahead grab hold and pick it up come
on monkey is this ok
this is really heavy Oh at least guys
are really easy to wear that's okay
before heading out we have to fill up at
an outlet it takes 20 minutes to charge
the one-wheel but the batteries only
have a reach of seven kilometers the air
will has the longest which it can go 30
kilometers on a charge the plug on the
rocket skates isn't easy to find their
batteries last 16 kilometres okay okay
you have to know that isn't
then we head out to the runway of
Berlin's decommissioned temple of
airport today the airfield is a public
park just the right place for us none of
these vehicles are street legal pad
sound required but they're a good idea
as we later find out the pro shows me
how to write the airwheel it can reach a
top speed of 30 kilometers an hour these
electric unicycles are produced by
several brands with prices ranging from
300 to 2,000 euros the rider stays and
stops by shifting his body weight the
hard part is getting on even after half
an hour practice I still need help and
I'm scared to let go beginners will have
to take a few hours to get the hang of
it after they shell out 1,850 euros for
it the next device is for the pro the
one will runs on one thick tire rock
sticks and bumps in the road are no
problem the top speed here is 25
kilometers an hour
the motor is inside the tire and the
census that activate it under the
board's if you ever stood up on a seesaw
as a child you know how to get on a
one-wheel you steal this one too by
shifting your weight leaning forward
speeds it up
I can go it alone but I'm still afraid
to go fast this one is my favorite the
big minus is the price fourteen hundred
euros and if it ever needs repair it has
to be sent back to the manufacturer in
the United States their rocket skates
look like something out of the 1980
science fiction film we expect to launch
like a rocket but even the pro is having
trouble these skates will only do 16
kilometers an hour theoretically and
practice it's not easy first you have to
push off and then press down with your
heels to activate the electric motor and
try not to fall the skate slip over your
own shoes I'm not even going to try to
launch like a rocket I'm happy just to
follow alone
but even with help I'm a failure all the
skates are please let me stop just as we
are about to give up help arrives the
highly skilled inline skater has been
watching us and wants to try out the
rocket skates even he has trouble at
first before he gets the hang of it the
skates are way too dangerous at least
for me I wouldn't take them as a gift
let alone pay 700 years they definitely
not for beginners I would advise not to
try this alone and even there is a
little electronic motor it's still
exhausting may be dangerous and rather
expensive but it is lots of fun
especially with this one
my conclusion you can break a bone just
walking but I think there's no use
tempting fate